bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo logo io sono qua dj noi oggi siamo
in un nuovo blog ha sbagliato a dire
nulla in do sbagliato la intro sono
passati un paio di mesi dall'ultimo blog
serio il che è veramente assurdo e
niente ragazzi un miliardo e mezzo di
robe da dirvi quindi cominciamo che che
è meglio prima di cominciare ragazzi e
ripartire con la fanar della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
alessandro che ha fatto aspettano non
era questo non è sbagliato era questa la
frase della settimana scusate è stata
vinta ragazzi da elettra c'è scritto qua
elettra grazie lettera per il disegno
perché è epico veramente grassi dico
anche quello di prima non era male però
allora ragazzuoli c'è un miliardo e
mezzo di cose da dirvi sul serio la
prima cosa ragazzi che avrete
sicuramente già notato ed è sceso anche
gesù a ringraziarmi per questo dopo ben
tre mesi che vivo in questa casa qui ho
deciso di mettere lo sfondo è fantastico
[Musica]
se vi state chiedendo che mutande sono
quelle sono mutande di star wars nel
caso mi stesse chiedendo perché sono in
mutande perché a casa mia fa caldo me
l'hanno regalata ai miei amici queste
qua perché non so perché ho fatto le del
mio culo nei blog comunque siccome io
c'ho la casa tappezzata di robe di star
wars
me l'hanno regalato i miei amici perché
mi mancavano breemen teso le mutande la
prossima volta che prova a rimorchiare
una bella donzella e le mostrerò la mia
spada laser nel senso questa qui
quanto minchia trash questo blog corano
lo avevo messo a posto perché non avevo
voglia
non ho trovato la voglia in tre mesi
pensate quando mia madre mi dice di
riordinare la stanza che voglia c'è
un'altra news epica ragazza questa
questa veramente epica il mio libro
ragazzi sotto le cuffie ha raggiunto
anzi astra superato le 50.000 copie
vendute che pazzesco è veramente che non
è la mia autobiografia non mi son
raccontato come persona ciò vent'anni
che cazzo devo raccontare semplicemente
il mio percorso da youtuber dagli inizi
fino ad arrivare qui ed è stato per
adesso è stato veramente assurdo e spero
che continui tra continui mi hanno dato
la mondadori mi ha dato il libro d'oro e
sarebbe tipo il disco di platino per per
i cantanti e ai suoi che melo figlio
sarebbe questo ragazzo si vede il
riflesso del blog nel computer
fantastico vabbè mica ragazzi alla fine
il premio è lo lascio qua per terra
passiamo oltre perché sono già un
miliardo di punti sono qualità che regga
solidi c'è un'altra news ha preso
ragazzi la nuova videocamera perché
voglio provare a fare blog ho già
registrato delle cose fuori casa voglio
provare a documentare qualche giornata
[ __ ] e metterla come video aggiuntivo
della serie ogni tanto capita che
usciranno due video in un giorno questo
secondo nido sarà un video tipo un blog
che faccio in giro spero che vi piaccia
l'idea il fascio di forlì esempio di
cosa dovrebbe uscire fuori c'è il
bambino li che ha la mia stessa identica
cioè mio stesso identico giubbotto
uguale
e uguale non è che mi riprendo a mentre
va dal sesso per carità e tu proprio tu
anzi no già l'ho fatto va bene quindi
ragazzoni detto questo viene di passare
allo scartarlo dei pacchi e siccome sono
nella casa nuova ragazzi non mi possono
arrivare pacchi perché non ho il punto
posta però questi pacchi quali avete
dati al all'ultimo raduno passiamo al
primo ragazzi che il più piccolo carcere
c'era questa cosa dentro ma esce fuori
in a taranto la viva però successo ma
che cada anche è un cappello se c'è
questa roba qui smi ma va per figo nono
genialissimo chi cazzo è statica me l'ha
mandata se no no ma non avete capito
adesso in avanti vado per strada a
rimorchiare con questo qui grazie di
cuore per carità epico apriamo al
prossimo e poi ragazzi cè un
braccialetto che c'è scritto four e per
sempre per infinito cuore per infinito
in realtà mi chiamo lorenzo quindi loro
non fare però grazie perfetto ragazzo
trovato il gemello che addio mana e
maestro di kung fu panda non somiglia un
po perché include ragazzi l'ultimo io
non è che gli aprì paris iv cos'è kong
combo combo force collect the mall bici
ma è così che si montano aspetti così
messo altro dentro proprio con beaufort
ma spiega io a montare i costi sono un
genio da piccolo riuscivo sempre giusto
alla italia sono dei comics sì perché
non li conoscesse son tipo pupazzi che
che combattono più di crei e combattono
mi incazzo mi sento un ingegnere ragazzi
no seriamente voglio creare così ai temi
atti un miliardo se ne ho montato un
altro ragazzi che ci ha messo un'ora e
mezza vi giuro ci ho messo un'ora e
mezza sul serio che però non riesco a
montarli l'altro braccio madonna e non
monta io non so montare le cose ecco gli
manca un braccio a testa fantastico ha
vinto ha vinto lui ha vinto lui perché è
rimasto sulla scrivania all'altra è
morto non riesco a montare mai niente ma
ma anche i mobili che compro takata
ragazzi questi erano i pacchi di oggi
sempre bella questa frase da dire è che
gli passava il fa vi risponde prima
domanda rivas d'alessandro pona che mi
dice avevo studia avevo studiato tutta
la settimana ma giorno dopo la shopper
avevi studiato
sei proprio sicuro di aver studiato c'è
qualcosa che mi dice che non ha mai
studiato luigi mi chiede ascolti genere
chi può allora in realtà si a me piace
un sacco e che hip hop in generale ci
salveremo le canzoni veramente [ __ ]
tipo di emozioni col calcio che sono
stupende non conoscete mi emozioni col
calcio credete che vi stia prendendo in
giro cosa diresti a tutte le ragazze che
non hanno più speranza di vederti e
quindi ci stanno male ti voglio bene ma
so quanto convenga conoscere un
cristiano che fai video con con le
mutande vista ruolo annachiara fare gli
spender che fossi se incontrassi
skrillex per strada e da taglio
incontrato davvero skrillex medium e che
ho fatto e mi son bagnato alessandro
fare risponde fa vicoletto segreto della
non crescita e ai 22 anni non è manco un
pelo sulla fascia in 15 e già vi spunta
la barba e la camionista ma no in realtà
è che io non ho vent'anni dal torneo 15
solo che se avessi detto sin dall'inizio
che ho 15 anni nessuno mi avrebbe mai
cacciato prima che qualcuno ci creda sto
scherzando ne ho 21 quasi fra il
compenso cioè dei cappelli figli
c'è questo compensa la mia figaggine
soprattutto i peli cielo sulle gambe
cosa molto sexy
quindi ragazzi e che posso concludere
che mi chiami mancava un blog serio che
era da un secolo che non facciamo blog
seri come favi davanti ragazzi fatemi
sapere se vi piace di già quella dei
blog che voglio fare in giro
niente ragazzi fatemi tante domande
perché mi mancavano per questo blog
visto che non ne facciamo da secoli
quindi fatemi anche un sacco di domande
qui sotto alle quali risponderà nel
prossimo blog
niente ragazzi spero che ai video vi sia
piaciuto cose se vi è piaciuto il
documento è un mi piace anche allo
sherry facebook il come nei video total
descrizione del city 16 20 euro possono
vinto bello ragazzi